[Music]
hello everyone
so in the previous part of the lecture
we had
discussed the question
what is going to happen if
if we considered the finite strain
tensor
as we had seen here but we considered
that these linear terms have very small
magnitude
so this is the first important
note we are going to consider
so if
this generic term del ui del xj
it has a very small magnitude meaning
that
this is very much less than one and you
please note
that let me write that properly
this is much much less than
1 so you please note that
this entire term the del u by del xj
that is dimensionless meaning
that ui that is
a component of the displacement vector
and it has the dimension of length
similarly the xj it is a component
of the position vector and it also has
the
dimension of length so in the numerator
and denominator we both have length
so overall this term has the is
dimensionless
so it is perfectly all right to say that
the magnitude of this term
is much much less than 1 we don't need
to put any unit here
but what is the implication of this that
if
this is true the magnitude of this term
is much much less than 1
then you can see if we go back to the
previous
page here that this magnitude is much
much less than 1
let's say it is something like 0.1
or perhaps even less than that and this
also
all has a magnitude which is much much
less than 1 because you note that when
you are writing this
this is a generic term it is it does not
mean
that we cannot be considering
[Music]
this equality to be not holding true if
we perhaps write
this as del u k del xj this is a generic
term it does not mean
that here if we come back it is only
this del u y del x j which can be less
than less than one
this is a generic expression you might
as well have written this as
del u p del x q or del u
m del u x l anything goes
uh so this generic term if it is less
than
much much less than 1 then
this one and this one the multiplication
of them suppose this is 0.1
and this also is let's say 0.2
then this becomes overall 0.02 which is
even less than one
even smaller so you see this is
like 0.1 this is like 0.1
of that order and this is one order less
than that
because it's a multiplication of two
small numbers both less than one
so we may to a good engineering
approximation say
that if this is holding true that uh
the del ui del xj magnitude is more
smaller than one
then for all intents and purposes this
quadratic term
can very well be dropped okay
so under this consideration we can say
that
e i j is approximately equal to
half of del ui
del xj plus
l u j del x i
we do not write anymore under this
consideration
the quadratic terms now this particular
expression
it no longer contains any quadratic
terms and this
is this particular form is defined
[Music]
to be
this thing epsilon i j so we say or we
define
that whenever we have this particular
combination we define that to be equal
to
epsilon i j so earlier we had written
the
we've written it in the reverse fashion
that we had written a symbol like this
that column equal to
that is the uh so we if you have a
symbol here
so whatever you write on the right hand
side that will be the definition for
this
and here what we are doing is we have an
expression
and then we are choosing to define that
expression
uh in this form so it is just the
reverse way
so
so with this understanding
you note that
this has a very special name so earlier
we had seen that the f
e i j capital e i j that is referred to
as the finite strain tensor
now with this new definition the epsilon
i
j equivalent
to this this is the
infinitesimal strain tensor
sometimes it is also referred to as
small strain tensor
okay now just as we had discussed
earlier
uh this epsilon i j having uh
in its subscript two free indices that
is also a second order tensor
so uh again just like e i just so let me
just quickly refer back to the previous
slide we had said that this is a second
order tensor
so is epsilon i j e i j is equal to e j
i similarly here
epsilon i j will be equal to
epsilon j i so
symmetric
and you see that this eij can be
represented as a 3 into 3 matrix
similarly this epsilon i j can also be
represented as a 3 into 3 matrix
however we are not going to write down
just for the sake of repetition this
epsilon 1 1 epsilon 1 to all these
things
instead what we are going to do is uh
something which is very much practical
and useful
for the purpose of our current course of
mechanics of solids
so in many many textbooks you will see
that uh
this kind uh of an index notation is
hardly ever used
uh primarily because those textbooks are
aimed at first-year engineering students
but you are no longer first-changing
students rather you are third-year
engineering students
so
what is so the connection between that
kind of a notation and this index
notation
where you are using x1 x2 x3
is that
so we can say that the x1
it corresponds to small x
the x 2 it corresponds
to y and the x 3
it corresponds to z so what i'm trying
to do here
is to establish a connection
between this general very general
mathematical framework
and the more common mathematical
framework
which most of you are familiar with
which is
referred to the rectangular cartesian
coordinate system
where the coordinate variables are the
familiar x
y and z coordinate system so if we
fall back to that kind of framework what
happens is that
correspondingly the different components
of the displacement vector
that are given by these
so u1 corresponds to u so this is simply
a change of notation so to speak
the u2 is given by v and the u3 is given
by
w so overall what we can say
is epsilon 1 1
that is epsilon
x x in this new framework
and that the expression of that
is del
u del x
we don't even have to use a bracket and
remove this thing
we don't also don't need the half
because you see what you're basically
having here is half
del u1 del x1 plus del u1 del x1 so that
is just del u1 del x1
and that is nothing but del u del x
so this is simply
del u del x
for epsilon 2 2 what we have
is
[Music]
that is epsilon yy and that is nothing
but del p del y
which corresponds to del u 2 del x 2
epsilon 3 3 that corresponds to
epsilon z z and that is equal to
del w del z
furthermore we have or epsilon 1 2
that is epsilon x y and you understand
that epsilon 1 2 is equal to epsilon 2 1
so epsilon x y is equal to epsilon y yx
and that is equal to
now here we need the half because they
don't add up
like before when we had the expression
for epsilon xx
so you understand here that this del u
del y it is coming from
del u 1 del x 2
and this del v del x it is coming from
del u 2 del x is 1
similarly epsilon 2 3 is going to
correspond to
epsilon y z and that is equal to
half of
del v del
z plus del w
del y and finally
epsilon p1 that corresponds to
epsilon zx
and that is equal to half of
[Music]
del w del x
plus del u
del z
so just for the sake of completeness i
will
write this as very explicitly as
this is equal to epsilon y x
and this is equal to epsilon
z y and this is equal to
epsilon exit
now uh these first three terms epsilon
x x epsilon y y epsilon z z
these are referred to as the normal
strains
or the normal strain components
whereas these three
rather b6 because actually you have
epsilon xy
is equal to epsilon yx all these six
they are referred to as the
shear strain now every year
i teach this it is always a little bit
of a confusion
uh corresponding to what you perhaps had
learned in your first year
uh because uh i think some of you came
across
the term gamma x y or gamma y z in your
first year mechanics books
and perhaps that was referred to as the
shear string so there is no confusion
actually
you can just note down that
whatever we have defined like this here
the epsilon x y
that is nothing but half
of gamma x y
is equal to half of gamma
y x similarly this thing
whatever this expression we have found
out that is equal to
half of gamma z y equal to half of gamma
y z similarly this thing
is equal to half of gamma
xz is equal to half of gamma
zx so it is just uh from the context you
can
understand like what which expression
you have to use
so if gamma is used uh don't use the
half here
and just write down these expressions
and if epsilon is used
so just use the half here okay
so overall what we can say is that
these relations that we have written
down here primarily
this the six independent relations for
epsilon x
x epsilon y y epsilon z z
uh and epsilon x wipes and y then
epsilon zx
these are referred to together as the
strain displacement relations
[Music]
the expressions of epsilon x x epsilon y
y
epsilon z z epsilon
x y epsilon y z
and epsilon zx in
terms sorry in terms
of the
derivatives
[Music]
in terms of the
derivatives of the
[Music]
of the displacement vector components
that is del u del x del v del y all
these things that we had obtained
earlier
uh so all these expressions
they are referred to as
so i'm writing this in capital letters
to denote how important these relations
are
these are referred to as the strain
displacement relations
you note down very quickly that we are
no longer referring to this
as the small strain or the infinite
symbol string
so in the absence of any special
qualifier whenever you come across the
word string you understand that
implicitly
means the infinite symbol of the small
string tension
so the strain displacement relations are
what we had obtained
in this in this part here
okay and these will be extremely
extremely important these strain
displacement relations
as long as you are talking anything
related to mechanics of solids
or elasticity in general uh it will be
extremely extremely important for
solving very various problems as well as
for developing
uh our theory okay now
very quickly we will just write this
this string tensor in the matrix
representation
so
because this is such an important topic
i am
spending a lot of time in representing
the things in various forms
[Music]
so this is a w
this is w
so this term that i have just written
here is exactly the same as this term
[Music]
[Music]
again this term that i have just written
is exactly equal to this term
and this term that i have written is
exactly equal to this term
and finally we have this
so this is in the form of a matrix
so all these strain displacement
relations they are encapsulated
in this kind of a matrix form here okay
so one final thing uh
the earlier expression that we had
obtained
so this one
this thing so under the consideration
that
del uy del xj this magnitude
is much much less than one uh what we
have
is this thing is
equal to epsilon
i j because when we have already seen
that when this is true
so e i j is approximately equal to
epsilon i j
so ah this is what is holding true now
all right so uh in the next part of the
lecture
we are going to uh discuss how we may
further re-represent this particular
equation uh in a slightly more
convenient form
uh okay thank you